brought to you by msi computers msi
number one in gaming find out more at us
msi com Assassin's Creed syndicate we
saw some more Assassin's Creed syndicate
snow we did it so a senior trailer we
saw CGI trailer which which looks almost
as close to gameplay that I feel like
I'm being cheated when I watch it
because it kind of looks like a coding
right that good but it doesn't and Kevin
what are your thoughts on sendagaya I'm
sort of iffy at this point just because
they oh they always know how to pick a
good song for a trailer so plus there um
but it's it's just a sass and Crete and
I can't believe I've got this thing on
my arm and I'm saying this hey those
four games really good they were but I
don't know like I'm at the stage where
I'm just like I needed to see more there
was nothing more of Assassin's Creed I
mean they're all there will be more at
the show nearly that'll be playable and
that kind of thing I think but I don't
know just that in and of itself plus
this is really nitpicky but if somebody
who's played so much Assassin's Creed
the lighting and the colors are sort of
bothering me yeah because the trailer
sort of had some of the same that the
yellow has just been cranked up so high
good lighting and dissipated driving me
insane and we saw that in the the
gameplay footage that they also showed
that the yellow has been cranked up so
high dislike I find it don't work much
better obviously because it's CG but
just even in terms of the style I just
prefer this so much better something
about the lighting and the gameplay
we've seen that really irks me and I
just just all of this could look schlow
szon off to gameplay yeah it's just a
little bit jarring I mean if you're
gonna kill some horses you might as well
tell god I hated this at least they
might as well be English yeah I mean
what good is an emotion yeah facebook
hahaha it's the equine leap of faith
yeah yeah this is a renowned for being
really able to take full take a fall on
the face Alexei we're looking forward to
seeing the other protagonist of this
trailer as well and they didn't do it no
I'm disappointed because we've seen two
bits of gameplay and trailers now and
there they keep saying oh this is gate
this game is about Jacob and Evie Frye
and they talk about the twins and how
they're both important but we now have
two very lengthy CGI trailers just focus
focusing on this male protagonist and
it's doubly disappointing because it
Bethesda yesterday we got two trailers
with that you can play as a man or women
and they had the dishonored if the
option to play as either and they chose
to focus on Emily I wonder if this is
their PR team deciding that they're
going to leave all that stuff till the
last yeah are just for six months
showing him off last six months showing
her off we'll have to wait and see but
it did seem a little bit weird because
they've been teasing her for so long to
then spend six minutes showing off this
dude again the whiskey just looks like a
British Ezio kind of a jerk facial hair
looks dumb a beloved I guess we'll have
to wait and see any other thoughts on on
this bubbly Lucy yeah I mean we're gonna
be seeing it on the gamespot stage
actually you should check out where
we're gonna have hopefully actual game
plays I'm excited to see that so I mean
yeah it's Assassin's Creed I'll play it
I know I will there's no point saying
that i won't i want to get real excited
for Assassin's Creed game I know right
right yeah like I don't I think all four
of us are people who enjoy sasses Creed
but it's just yeah hard to guess it's
not hot get hyped up right now have this
hard and that's coming at this counter
here so fingers crossed we'll see some
more and fingers crossed we'll have some
more coverage as well in the game spot
stage so make sure you stay tuned in
case what com for more of that
Oh